foreign
[Music]
engineers at Google Cloud welcome back
to the technical guide for startups the
grow Series where we create a series of
videos for technical enablement we are
thrilled to help you start build and
grow your businesses successfully and
sustainably on Google Cloud
in our last episode sanskriti and Elise
walked us through how you could
architect a blockchain startup on Google
Cloud
today in the seventh video of the grow
series we pie and I we take you through
how you can start innovating with ML
Solutions on Google file we will be
covering the various ml Solutions
available on Google Cloud
what is ccai what you can bring for your
businesses and how it helps other
customers
how Doc AI can help with your document
processing needs what use cases it can
solve and how other customers are using
it
finally a list of resources to get you
started on innovating
Google cloud has an umbrella of machine
learning products and solutions that
your businesses can leverage we have
done a deep type of a few of these in
our previous videos so let's do a quick
recap of what we've covered so far
we can broadly classify ml Solutions
under three categories on Google Cloud
use as is customize and build under
build we have our text AI to help solve
business problems using data and
increase productivity with aim to end mL
of services check out our video getting
started with vertex AI to know more
under customized we have automl which
help businesses with limited ml
expertise to start building their own
high quality custom models
under use as is we have two vertical
Solutions Talent solution and
recommendation AI Talent solution
leverages ml technology to help better
Understand Job content and job Seeker
intent
use as is also encompasses ml apis which
we have covered in the video how to get
started with ML apis
we also have two horizontal Solutions
doc Ai and ccai which we will be
covering in detail in this video
conversation is a fundamental building
block of customer interactions and
contact centers we want you to fully
enable and Revelation the very same
technology that we have integrated and
built for Google at the core of our
conversational AI is technology that
helps enable a conversation with a
machine that enables natural
interactions with virtual agents
understand what customers are saying
talk to the customer in a natural Manner
and interact with a customer in a
conversation we have stt or speech to
text TTS or text to speech and
dialogflow as a building blocks to the
conversational AI for text and voice
nccai is built on top of this building
blocks the virtual agent powered by the
low flow with speech AI
provides both a text and voice channel
for call containment for common core
topics for more complex topics that
require Human Service agent we have
agent assist the listen into ongoing
conversation and promise assistance to
the Human Service agents through
knowledge base lookup and recommended
resolution steps this will challenge an
average handling time and provides more
consistent call Quality across call
center agents
and finally we have insights where all
the conversations are stored in a single
place you can do a lot of analysis and
modeling and you can also find a graph
and chart to see what is the top reason
that the customer contact you
and generally we were working with the
telephony partner like a wire and
Genesis to help our customers to utilize
this technology and drive this into
their own business
in 2023 we are offering a new product
the ccai platform to give our customers
more options when deploying ccai
customer can show ccai platform for
contact center as a service in our cloud
or continue with the existing investment
in their call Center Software like
genesis Avaya lines and Cisco and so on
today we don't want Mill ccai platform
we give the choices for our customers to
choose to use ccai either from Google
file or from our partner ccai platform
gives us integration and really brings
this unified platform
it can consolidate the Della flow agent
assist and insights together to cover
many different needs that the customers
might have
is really a turnkey solution for ccni to
make deploying and using this
conversational AI easier and quicker
contact center AI provides our customers
the orchestration capability to fully
leverage Google cloud and our ecosystem
from workspace Chrome all the way down
to the building blocks of AI and
infrastructure
now let's take deep dive into each ccai
building block
well dialogflow helped with your agent
designers and developers build faster by
providing many pre-built agent templates
and components and it doesn't require
deprogramming or machine learning skills
it can also improve customer experience
with frequently asked questions info box
searing and transactions you can also
engage more efficiently with Advanced
natural language processing and maximize
reach by languages and platform
Integrations supported by dialogflow
secondly agencies Focus entirely on
giving agents the right data at the
right time ensuring that both agent and
the customer have better experience
whether it's contacts us they begin the
conversation or helpful directions with
frequent artificial and knowledge based
answers to summarizing the interaction
when it's done easing their wrap-up
process
and that's where the inside comes in
sights can turn your customer
interactions into insights through our
built-in conversational AI understanding
and topic modeling capabilities that are
extendable by your call center analysis
the inside scan can help make a Better
Business decisions those business
decisions are going to help Drive
operational efficiency across a variety
of your company
ccai insights integrates with all other
contacts under AI solution products
allowing you to import conversations
from dialogflow and agent assist contact
center AI Insight helps user detect and
visualize pattern in the contact center
data understanding conversational data
helps Thrive business value improve
operational efficiency and provide a
voice for customer feedback
you can import your contact center
interaction data into insights in order
to run machine learning analytics or to
automatically identify interesting
interactions and reveal the conversation
all data include transcribe highlights
topic sentiment and entities gets
exported into bigquery data set and
insight table
ccai insights allows you to export your
ctai insights conversation and Analysis
data to bigquery so that you can perform
your own route query allow you to build
any custom analysis or visualization in
any tools like looker Luca studio and so
on
we are happy to share our customer
success story from Taylor's from your
data in 2021 there's always 20 million
customer conversations per year imagine
if we could transcribe every customer
call into a customer intent that we
could take action on the ccai will give
them the transcribed data asset of
customer intents for every customer call
this asset will be used to help Drive
multiple commercial outcomes including
the digital personalization use case and
contact center analytic use cases the
result is so impressive tailors can
reduce the customer effort for 7 and 200
hours per year and reduce agent effort
for 2.3 million US dollars per year now
let's see a quick demo on ccai insights
in this demo we are trying to improve
the customer experience of the
electronic shop that sell devices and
tools and behind the scene this is
running on the advanced natural language
model on Google Cloud
first thing we will do is to import a
child transcript into Insight here we
have 10 000 generated conversations
which store in our bucket and you can
either import by Json format or audio
and the insights will handle the
transcription for you
I will use insight to identify the most
common topics in our conversation data
it uses topic modeling to group the
conversation into relevant cluster
we can click on the start training and
you can take up the few hours we will
come back after it completed to take a
look on the result
this is how the result look like we got
seven different topics discover all the
data and the best part is Insight did
everything but as superwise learning we
can deploy this model so that insights
can use this to analyze the conversation
now if I'm
if I'm there for agent I noted my
customer are likely to have these seven
kind of problems so you can build the
dialog flow or the virtual agent to help
them solve the issues in addition to
high level topic we can analyze the
conversation in more details using the
topic model we can configure the
fraction of conversation that should be
analyzed automatically here we can go
through one of them in details in this
conversation it seems like a customer
has a problem with a streaming device it
wasn't turning on and they're trying to
use troubleshooting wizard this
conversation is 6 minutes long and had
14 turns so now I can identify which
conversation I can explore in more
detail and improve the virtual agents
another technique that we can use to
learn our conversation data is
conversation highlight
smart highlights are built in the
insights and can detect the important
attributes in the conversation this also
has some highlights where you can track
your own tag like laptop phone or
Internet it looks like most of our
customers have pop and with the internet
issues so we can add some intent or
resources to our virtual agents in
dialogflow
finally now you understand how the
inside fits in as a part of the contact
center AI on Google Cloud
thanks mile for showing us how
businesses can leverage ccai for their
call center needs
with the recent shift to remote and
hybrid work and an increasingly digital
world we have adopted a paperless route
and a lot of documents have now become
digitized
think of all the PDFs forms emails and
contracts you have used to consume or
relay information
these documents essentially make up a
gold mine of data that businesses can
leverage to derive insights and drive
business decisions enter document AI
document AI is an end-to-end Cloud
platform for document processing which
turns unstructured content into
structured data with data in a
structured format you can begin to make
it useful
maybe you want to run analytics on
customer feedback or you're processing
large multi-page application forms the
possibilities are endless
document AI helps with document
processing tasks you can use it to
digitize text from documents this means
you can extract text words paragraphs
blocks symbols and even correct rotation
document AI also helps in pre-processing
documents with image quality detection
and this queuing
labeling and reviewing can also be done
with document AI
you can split and classify documents
based on type
this would be helpful when for example
you have scanned a bunch of different
procurement documents into a single PDF
or file and you need to programmatically
switch the documents based on logical
boundaries
you can also use it to process
industry-specific documents document AI
workbench can be used when you need to
create a custom model specific to your
business
now I know I threw around a few
processor names so let's understand the
different processors document AI has to
offer
first we have General processors that
are pre-built processors that are
compatible with most document types
under General processors we have
document OCR and the form passer
second we have specialized processors
that are pre-built processors for
specific document types
this includes procurement documents
which are used for payments and
purchases such as receipts and invoices
identity documents that are used for
identity verification lending documents
that are used for mortgage loans and
business contracts lastly we have custom
user creative processors if you have a
unique type of document and want to get
the same detailed information from it
this can be achieved with the help of
document AI workbench
document AI offers the ability to obtain
existing specialized processors or
create new processors completely from
scratch in order to get the most
accurate information from any document
type
these work very similarly to automl with
vertex AI so you don't have to write any
tensorflow or Pi torch code to start
training the model however there is a
certain criteria to be met while working
with document AI workbench a minimum of
20 documents is required to train a
custom document extractor or uptrain a
specialized processor
you will reserve a minimum of 10
documents for training and 10 for
testing you need a minimum of 10
annotations per schema label
task the customer or a partner needs to
be resourced to label the documents
with the many processor types available
it can get confusing to select which
processor to use in a given situation
this decision tree gives us a quick
overview of which processor to use let's
go through it in a bit more detail
if your requirements are to only extract
the text and the layout then the OCR
processor is a way to go it lets you
identify and extract text including
handwritten text
the form passer is more useful in cases
when you want to extract General key
value pairs for example entity and check
boxes tables and other generic entities
which are present in documents apart
from OCR text
if you need to process documents with a
specific layout and a specialized
processor is already available you can
then leverage these pre-trained
processors or uptrain them
by up training we mean that you begin
with a pre-made model and then train
this model with your own data to improve
its accuracy
if our available specialized processors
do not cover a document type that you
would like to process then you can use
document AI workbench to create a custom
processor provided that it meets the
criteria outlined in the previous
section
in case a criteria can't be met you can
offer OCR processor and automl
with the help of automl natural language
you can create and deploy custom machine
learning models that can analyze
documents categorize them and identify
entities
let's go through a sample dock AI
architecture you can either use the
batch or the online API calls to process
documents using document AI with batch
or asynchronous calls these use
documents which are stored in Google
cloud storage and can write the results
back to it online or synchronous calls
allow you to send a document within a
request and receive the results
synchronously you can then use a
serverless processing pattern via Cloud
functions Cloud functions are good for
actions that you might want to keep
separate from your main app code and
deploy Monitor and maintain separately
just like Doc AI if it's a separate
integration point to your system you
could wrap your doc AI API calls in a
cloud function and then attach it via an
HTTP Trigger or you could create a
background Cloud function that gets
triggered by events that happen in your
cloud storage bucket let's move on to
the demo so we can get a glimpse of the
functionality doc AI has to offer if you
head over to the document AI
documentation on the left pane you will
see your try it option which essentially
provides a drag and drop feature to let
you try out the different processors
as you can see you have the option to
test the various processors either with
a document on your local machine or with
one of the readily available samples
for the purpose of this demo I'll be
using a sample form to test the form
passer if I zoom into the form you will
see a health intake form with various
Fields such as name address
phone number medical concerns Etc on the
left pane you can see the list of key
value Pairs and you can even filter the
results based on the field if I type in
state I can access the value associated
with the field on the top pane if we
select the Json tab we can view the
request URL the request and the response
in Json format in case you need to
integrate doc AI into your application
and make a call to the API the Json
response may be easier to work with to
extract the identified values
to create a specialized processor on the
console head over to the document AI
platform overview click create processor
and scroll down to specialized and
select invoice parser give it a name and
select the closest region on the list
click create to create your processor
foreign
document and select an invoice to pass
as we can see the various Fields along
with their values have been extracted in
a key value pair format we can also
classify and split documents in this
example we'll be using the procurement
processor
let's create a python file that will use
the online processing API to classify
and detect logical split points for a
multi-page document
I will create a file called
classification.py and replace processor
underscore ID with the ID of the
procurement splitter processor I created
earlier replace project underscore ID
and location with the cloud project ID
and the processor location respectively
after running the file the procurement
splitter classifier correctly identified
the document Types on pages 0 to 1 and 3
to 4. page 2 contains a generic medical
intake form so the classifier correctly
identified it as other the code for the
python file is available in the code lab
Linked In the description
after witnessing the capabilities of
document Ai and how we can transform
document processing many customers have
started leveraging it one such customer
is Senex senix is an Australian natural
gas producer using document AI Senex was
able to unlock data that could be used
to optimize well design and operations
as a result Cenex can also look for
Trends such as safety issues across
their assets before determining if the
issue needs to be addressed
as stated by Timothy Corcoran the
general manager for digital Senex Google
Cloud demonstrated impressive built-in
OCR capability it took minimal efforts
by our team to pull the Trap data from
handwritten notes and PDF documents and
turn it into useful information that
could be used to run our business
if you would like to know more about CCA
and Doc AI there are a ton of resources
to help you get started
here are field links you can go through
in the description
you'll be able to read up more on ccai
and Dot AI
check out our YouTube playlist
experience our Hands-On tutorials and
lastly please stay connected to learn
more our next video
if you are interested in using document
AI you can start with the document AI
documentation which has sample code
examples and an extensive list of the
available parcels
we also have a document AI playlist
called the future of documents which
includes a deep dive into each of the
document AI processors and demos
illustrating how you can use them
finally you can get Hands-On with the
cloud skills boost Labs or the code Labs
that provide step-by-step tutorials that
brings us to the end of this video in
our next video we will go over learning
the fundamentals of ml arts in detail
and how you can achieve it on Google
Cloud we will then go through a demo and
inspiring customer story and that's a
wrap as always don't forget to like And
subscribe to our YouTube channel click
on the Bell icon to get notified each
time a new video is posted thank you so
much and stay tuned
foreign
[Music]